[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
HAPPY THURSDAY, EVERYONE, AND
BOY IS IT A HAPPY ONE!
BECAUSE I ALMOST MADE IT THROUGH
THE WEEK WITHOUT BEING STABBED
OR SHOT.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
ALTHOUGH TWICE SECURITY STOPPED
DANA PERINO JUST IN TIME.
BUT ALL OF US HERE IN THE STUDIO
HAD SOMETHING IN COMMON.
WE AREN'T DEAD.
AT LEAST YET.
BECAUSE IN NEW YORK CITY, NOT
GETTING ASSAULTED IS AKIN TO
WINNING THE LOTTERY.
IT'S A VIOLENT CITY RIGHT NOW.
THIS MORNING I SAW A RAT WITH A
BLACK EYE.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
IT'S A FUNNY IMAGE.
IT'S NOT EVEN A REAL JOKE, BUT
HEY.
MURDERS SPIKED BIG TIME JUMPING
FROM 319 IN 2019 TO 500 IN 2020.
WE SHY AWAY FROM NUMBERS AROUND
HERE BECAUSE B6 HATES MATH.
BUT CHANGE THAT VOWEL TO AN E
AND THAT'S ANOTHER STORY.
ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
THAT JUMP, BY THE WAY, WAS THE
LARGEST SINCE NATIONAL RECORD
KEEPING BEGAN IN 1960.
THAT WAS THE OTHER MOB FINALLY
STOPPED KILLING ALL THE RECORD
KEEPERS.
SO YES, WE MAY NOT BE NUMBER ONE
ANYMORE IN MATH OR SCIENCE BUT
CHECK OUT HOW WE KILL EACH
OTHER.
WHERE IS OUR GOLD MEDAL AND
THAT?
WE GOT TO HOST THE OLYMPIC GAMES
SO WE CAN ADD COMPETITIVE
DRIVE-BYS AS A NEW SPORT.
BUT AS THE MEDIA QUICKLY POINTS
OUT ALL THE TIME, IF YOU REMOVE
MURDER FROM THE STATISTICS,
CRIME HAS DROPPED.
WELL, THAT'S A RELIEF!
SO HEY, HONEY, DID YOU HEAR THIS
YEAR?
YOU'RE LESS LIKELY TO GET
ROBBED.
WHY ARE YOU ANSWERING ME?
OH WOW, YOU'VE BEEN MURDERED.
BUT AT LEAST YOU WEREN'T ROBBED.
NOW LET ME MOVE YOUR BODY BEFORE
I GET ARRESTED FOR LITTERING.
MAYBE I'M CRAZY, BUT IF MURDER
NEARLY DOUBLES WHILE LESSER
STUFF IS DOWN, I'M NOT THROWING
A PARADE.
MAINLY BECAUSE NO ONE WILL SHOW
UP SINCE THEY'VE ALL BEEN
MURDERED.
SO THE CRIME WAVE AIN'T JUST NYC
EITHER.
CHICAGO HAD 771 MURDERS LAST
YEAR COMPARED TO 500 THE
PREVIOUS YEAR, ELLIE WENT FROM
258-2351.
THAT'S WHY THESE CITIES ARE
HEMORRHAGING RESIDENTS, BECAUSE
THE RESIDENTS ARE HEMORRHAGING.
MURDERS HAVE JUMPED 10% FROM
2020 AND 87 CITIES ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
AND SPEAKING OF MURDER, YOU KNOW
IT KILLED THE TIMES TO ADMIT
THAT.
SO THE TIMES IS IN FULL DENIAL.
TO THEM IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH DEFUNDING AND MARGINALIZING
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHILE CHEERING
ON THE DESTRUCTION OF CITIES OR
RELEASING REPEAT VIOLENT
OFFENDERS ONTO THE STREET, WHICH
THEY HAVE, ESSENTIALLY
DECRIMINALIZING CRIME.
NO, NO, IT'S NOT THAT.
TO QUOTE A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
IN THE PIERCE "PEOPLE ARE
DESPERATE, AND THEY DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF OPTIONS SO THEY TURN TO
VIOLENCE AS THE WAGES ALL
THINGS."
IS THAT OF PERSON'S ONLY OPTION?
YOU KNOW, LOOK FOR A JOB OR KILL
SOMEONE.
CONGRATULATIONS, MEDIA, YOU'VE
DRESSED THE CITY IN SHORT SKIRT
AND SAID SHE WAS ASKING FOR IT.
IF YOU DON'T SEE THE CRIMINAL AS
THE PERPETRATOR BUT AS A VICTIM,
HAPPILY EXCUSE YOURSELF FROM
PUNISHING THE PERP.
HOWEVER, THE MEDIA WOULD SURELY
CHANGE THEIR MINDS IF THESE
CRIMES ARE BEING COMMITTED BY
TRUMP SUPPORTER'S.
SO WHAT IS NEW YORK CITY DOING
WELL CITIZENS ARE PICKED OFF
LIKE CLAY PIGEONS AT A SKEET
SHOOT?
THE BOARD OF HEALTH HAS DECLARED
RACISM A PUBLIC-CRISIS.
IF NOT MURDER, NOT DRUG ABUSE,
NOT PUNK AND SPICE LATTES, BUT
RACISM.
THOSE VICTIMS PUSHED ONTO SUBWAY
TRACKS?
I BET THEY'LL BE SO RELIEVED.
SO THEY PASSED A RESOLUTION
DECLARING THAT COVID HAS
WORSENED THE SUFFERING AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
IF THEY ARE REFERRING TO REST
HOMES, THEY MIGHT BE RIGHT.
BLACK, WHITE, BROWN, RACISM
DIDN'T KILL THEM THOUGH.
THE CARELESSNESS AND STUPIDITY
OF OUR POLITICIANS DID.
ONE STATE SENATOR SAID WE NEED
AN URGENT CALL TO ACTION, WE CAN
NO LONGER IGNORE AS A GOVERNMENT
OR A SOCIETY.
YET, BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN IGNORING
RACISM.
SORRY, WHERE HAS THIS IDIOT
BEEN?
THE ONLY PLACE WHERE RACISM
ISN'T BEING DISCUSSED AT NAUSEA
HIM IS UNDER THE SEA, AND EVEN
THERE, THE GREAT WHITE SHARK
GETS A BAD RAP.
IT'S TRUE.
THIS RESOLUTION CAME SIX MONTHS
AFTER THE INEPT CDC DECLARED
RACISM A SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT, AND NOW THEY'VE CRATED A
MAYORAL RACIAL JUSTICE
COMMISSION.
WHO'S GOING TO BE IN CHARGE OF
IT?
THE MAYOR'S WIFE?
NO.
OUR MAYOR IS STUPID.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
BUT HIS WIFE IS WORSE!
SHE RAN THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM THAT MADE 800 MILLION
BUCKS OF TAXPAYER MONEY
DISAPPEAR!
AS A RESULT, WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
OUR STREETS LOOKS LIKE THE
TRAILER FOR THE SEQUEL TO "ONE
FLEW OVER THE CUCKOO'S NEXT."
IS RACISM A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS?
LET'S ASK THE ANGRY BLACK MALE.
♪ ♪
>> OH, HEY, GOT FELLED.
SORRY
I'M NOT GOING TO BE IN THIS
WEEK, REALLY UNDER THE WEATHER.
UNDER YOUR OPPRESSION.
WHITE DOUBLE.
I'M SORRY.
I GOT THE RACISM REALLY BAD THIS
WEEK.
[COUGHING]
OH, MAN, PUNKY!
PUNKY!
SORRY, YOU GUYS SHOULD
PROBABLY -- OH.
YOU KNOW -- I MEAN, I GUESS THE
GOOD NEWS DOUBLE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT ME
PERSONALLY, IT'S AN ILLNESS.
WONDER BREAD.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO MAYBE IT'S TRUE,
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, IF
YOU'RE A RACIST.
IF YOU THINK BEING A RACIST
OFFERS YOU ANY ADVANTAGE IN
LIFE, THEN YOU'RE WORSE THAN A
RACIST, YOUR JOY REID.
THE QUICKEST WAY TO END YOUR
LIFE, JUST BE A RACIST.
I WOULD HAVE ADDED BEING CAUGHT
WHACKING OFF ON THE WORK ZOOM
CALL, BUT CNN DID ME WRONG.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
BUT YOU CAN BE GUILTY OF RACISM
WITHOUT ANY PROOF AT ALL.
IT'S LIKE DUNKING WHICH IS, IF
THEY FLOAT THEY ARE GUILTY, BUT
IF THEY ARE INNOCENT, THEY
DROWN.
AND IF THEY GET HEPATITIS, THE
WATER IS DEFINITELY FROM KAT'S
HOT TUB.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU CALL IT, IT'S
DESIGNED TO GET AROUND YOUR
DENIAL OF BEING A BIGOT.
YOUR BLOOD RUNS RED, WHITE, AND
RACIST, EXCEPT FOR THE ACCUSERS
WHO ARE SOMEHOW BORN THAT EVIL
GENE.
SO IS RACISM A PROBLEM?
SURE, BUT IT DIDN'T RAPE THAT
WOMAN ON A TRAIN IN PHILLY WHILE
PEOPLE FOUND IT, IT DIDN'T KILL
THAT FILIPINO NURSE IN
TIMES SQUARE TWO WEEKS AGO,
RACISM DIDN'T STAND THAT OTHER
WOMAN DOWN A FLIGHT OF STAIRS TO
HER DEATH.
RACISM DIDN'T PUSH PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF TRAINS.
RACISM DIDN'T FORCE PEOPLE OUT
OF STORES THAT CAN NO LONGER
KEEP UP WITH THEFT.
OR MAYBE RACISM IS FUELING THIS.
WHAT ELSE COULD BE BEHIND THE
DENIAL OF SO MANY HOMICIDE RATES
KILLING SO MANY BLACKS?
THE WHITE ELITE ACTIVIST CLASS.
WHAT TO EXPECT FROM THESE
PEOPLE?
THAT'S THE RACISM, AND IT'S A
TRUE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
SERIOUSLY.
IF KOVIC WOULD REBUILD ANYTHING,
IT'S THAT LIVING UNDER DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP IS THE MOST DANGEROUS
COMORBIDITY ONE COULD HAVE.
TONIGHT'S GUEST!
VICE PRESIDENT -- CHRIS BARRON!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
THE BRILLIANT ECONOMIST ALWAYS
BRINGS A HIGH INTEREST RATE,
FINANCIAL ANALYST, HEATHER!
HE'S BIRTHED MORE TV SUCCESSES
THAN CHRISTIAN A BURIED TV RIDER
AND PRODUCER.
AND SHE'S THE ONLY PERSON THAT
OLIVE GARDEN SAID WASN'T FAMILY,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[SCATTERED CHEERS]
GOT A LOT OF FANS THERE, KAT.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY DRUNK.
WHEN YOU SEE STUFF LIKE THIS, DO
YOU WONDER HOW CAN THIS COUNTRY
SURVIVE WHEN LAWLESSNESS IS NOW
SOMEHOW GOVERNMENT APPROVED AND
THE CITIZENS GET TARGETED BY OUR
VERY OWN AGENCIES?
>> YEAH, EXCEPT FOR THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THE NEW YORK MAYOR
IS ON HIS WAY OUT AND A GUY ON
HIS WAY IN IS, YOU KNOW, WANT TO
RUN THE BOROUGHS OF MANHATTAN --
THE BOROUGHS OF NEW YORK CITY
HIM IS THAT WHAT YOU GUYS WANT
IN PLACES LIKE BROOKLYN AND
QUEENS IN THE BRONX AND THEY
SAID WE WANT MORE COPS AND HE
SAID OKAY.
HE RAN ON THAT AND HE WON, AND
HE'S GOING TO WIN PROBABLY A
DEMOCRATIC CITY -- IF THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE, PROBABLY
GOING TO WIN.
SO IT IS CORRECTING ITSELF A
LITTLE BIT.
WHAT I AM MOST WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT I THINK IS MORE FREAKY, A
LOT OF THESE CRIMES, A LOT OF
THESE MURDERS IN NEW YORK CITY
ARE COMMITTED BY INSANE PEOPLE
ON THE STREET.
AND THAT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS.
>> Greg: ABSOLUTELY.
IF YOU DRIVE UP ANY AVENUE LIKE
I DO EVERY DAY TO WORK BECAUSE
I'M A MAN OF THE PEOPLE --
MY DRIVER DRIVES ME!
CAN YOU SEE IT THROUGH THE
WINDOW?
IT'S TINTED.
AND IT WAS TOLD THE DRIVER NOT
TO SPEAK TO ME OR LOOK AT ME SO
I CAN CAPTURE -- BUT YOU GO ON
THE STREET, THERE ARE PEOPLE
LYING FACEDOWN ON THE GROUND AND
YOU CAN'T -- THEY ARE INSANE,
HEATHER.
YOU ARE A BUSINESS EXPERT.
HOW IS THIS AFFECTING, LIKE,
BUSINESSES.
THIS IS A NATIONWIDE ISSUE.
THERE ARE BUSINESSES THAT AREN'T
COMING BACK FROM COVID AND THEN
WHEN THEY COME BACK THEY ARE
DEALING WITH CRIME.
>> THE BUSINESSES THAT DID
SUCCEED, ESPECIALLY SMALL
BUSINESSES, THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC, NOW THEY ARE HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF ONE THEY
CALL THE POLICE, IF SOMEONE IS
ROBBING THE STORE, NOBODY SHOWS
UP ON TIME AND SO THEY HAVE TO
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE THERE LOSING A
LOT OF REVENUE DUE TO ALL THE
THEFT.
AND I JUST THINK -- WHEN THE
MURDER INCREASE WAS THE HIGHEST
HEAR OF YOUR SINCE THEY FOSTER
60s, 77% OF THOSE WERE CAUSED
BY FIREARMS, SO YOU WILL HEAR
THE DEMOCRATS BLAME GUNS.
THEY WILL SAY GUNS ARE THE
PROBLEM, BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
THERE'S NO SURPRISE THAT SURGING
VIOLENCE IN CITIES OF
MINNEAPOLIS AND PORTLAND AND
NEW YORK AND L.A. ARE ALL AREAS
WHERE THEY REDUCED THE POLICE
BUDGET.
THAT'S NO COINCIDENCE.
SO LAW-ENFORCEMENT RISK THEIR
LIVES EVERY DAY TO SAVE US, AND
I THINK THEY DESERVE A LOT MORE
RESPECT.
>> Greg: YEAH.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
IS IT TIME TO START DEFUNDING
THINGS THE DEMOCRATS LIKE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: LIKE THE ARTS?
>> HERE'S WHAT THE SADDEST THING
IS, THE LEFT-WING ACTIVIST TO
SAY THAT THERE'S ALL THIS
DESPERATION IN THE INNER CITIES,
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
FORTUNATELY, THE LEFT DOESN'T
HAVE ANY POLICY SOLUTIONS, SO
WHAT THEY OFFER UP IS THIS EMPTY
RHETORIC.
IT'S, YOU KNOW, IT'S RACISM,
IT'S BIGOTRY, IT'S HOMOPHOBIA.
THEY HAVE NO ACTUAL AGENDA TO
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
COMING TO GET PEOPLE WORKING, TO
GIVE PEOPLE OPPORTUNITY, AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
IT IS THE COMPLETE -- THE
EMPEROR HAS NO CLOTHES HERE.
WHILE THEY HAVE IS EMPTY
RHETORIC, AND THAT'S WHY --
THAT'S WHY WE CONTINUE TO SEE IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> Greg: LITERALLY WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE STREETS OF NEW YORK,
SOMETIMES THE EMPEROR -- YOU
KNOW WHAT THOUGH?
TO YOUR POINT, IF THE PROBLEMS
THAT THE LEFT CONCENTRATE ON,
YOU CAN CONCENTRATE ON IN TIMES
OF LUXURY.
THE REPUBLICANS COME TO POWER,
THEY BUILD AN ECONOMY.
THEN THE DEMOCRATS COME IN AND
TALK ABOUT UNDER DIVERSITY.
BUT NOW WE ARE IN CHAOS AND THEY
ARE STILL TALKING ABOUT THINGS
LIKE PRONOUNS WHILE EVERYBODY IS
SUFFERING.
WE NEED TO GET THE ADULTS BACK
IN THE ROOM, KAT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> DEPENDS ON WHICH ADULTS.
IN WHICH ROOM.
LIKE I WANT MORE COPS ON THE
STREET FOR SURE.
DO I WANT THEM SEARCHING MY
APARTMENT?
NOT NECESSARILY.
>> Greg: GOD NO.
>> BUT EVERYBODY SEES IT.
EVEN -- JUST YESTERDAY THERE WAS
A GUY PASSED OUT RIGHT ACROSS
THE SIDEWALK BY MY APARTMENT.
WE WERE CONCERNED, AS WE WALK
THE DOG, LIKE IS HE DEAD, HE
SAID NO, I'M JUST TAKING A NAP.
IT'S LIKE...
I HAVE TAKEN NAPS BEFORE.
YOU DON'T DO IT LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: IT IS -- THE BROKEN
WINDOWS THEORY HAS BEEN
DEBUNKED, BUT WE ARE FINDING
THAT IT WAS WRONGLY DEBUNKED,
THAT IF YOU ALLOW CERTAIN THINGS
LIKE THAT HAPPEN, IT ONLY GETS
WORSE.